Welcome students to
our lecture on the
antimalarial agents.
We'll be talking about
the prevention and
treatment of malaria.
Chemo is used
because the drugs are
actually chemicals, therefore
chemoprophylaxis and
treatment of malaria.
Here are the
learning objectives.
The first one, as you can
see, is to define terms.
It is the language of
antimalarial medications.
the usual preparation
materials.
Here is an outline. I'm
approaching this lecture
differently than other
lectures in the past.
As always I give you a
general overview and so I'm
giving you an overview of the
malaria endemic countries.
Also the lifestyle of the
malaria parasite which
is called plasmodium, the
clinical features of malaria,
so you can recognize
what malaria looks like,
and the goals of
therapy. Always think
about the goals.
What is it we are
trying to accomplish
with our treatment?
Then we'll talk about the
various drugs that are used
for prophylaxis, the drugs
that are used for treatment,
and then we'll go into
the actual pharmacology
of the individual drugs and
then finally the check your
knowledge questions and
then there is a summary that
will that puts all of this
information into tables
for easy access here are
the takeaways of the malaria
prophylaxis and treatment
concepts this lecture here
are key points on malaria
and clinical management,
and chemoprophylaxis and
treatment. So this can get
you into the picture if you
would like to have a look
at this in advance of
looking at the lecture video.
Definitions.
and let us begin.
These are the malarial
endemic regions.
You can see it cuts
right through the middle
of the earth in the warm
tropical areas mainly.
The orange is where malaria
cases are still being reported.
And the blue are areas
in which their programs
have been successful
to the point that there
have been no cases for
at least three years.
This is zero cases in this
region for one year as of 2017.
The white areas is where there
is no malaria in
the first place.
On the left-hand side are
the five malaria parasites
that cause illness and their
geographic distribution.
If you are prescribing
for a traveler to any
malaria endemic region,
it's important to know what
species of plasmodium is
causing illness there,
so that you can properly
prevent it, meaning
using the appropriate
drugs for that region. And
if patients come back
with signs and symptoms
of malaria after traveling
to these countries,
then you can know
what treatment
are most likely
to be effective.
artemisinin are very very
important drugs in the
treatment only the treatment
of malaria and resistance is
arising at this point it's
just partial resistance which
i'll talk about when we
get to this class of drugs.
So let's talk about
the life cycle
of the plasmodium.
We'll start here.
The Anopheles mosquito has a
blood meal from a human being.
The malaria parasite travels
to the liver, infects
the liver cells forms a
schizont. So this schizont
is where there's asexual
reproduction going on,
and we have these many,
many merozoites bursting
out of that ruptured
schizont in the liver tissue.
It's a hepatocyte.
Gets into the bloodstream,
and now gets into the red
blood cells, infects the
red blood cells. This is
a trophozoite which is a
ring stage. It's immature.
It can mature. We'll
follow around this way and
form schizont in the
red blood cell where the
merozoites now are forming
and the red cell bursts
releasing these merozoites
which go in to infect more
red blood cells and so
on and so on and so on.
The path that the ring
stage could also take is
to form a gametocyte.
This is the ****** form.
These are the asexual forms.
This can then be taken
up by the mosquito
in a blood meal and
then Then it will
form an oocyst and
more sporozoites.
And the sporozoites are
then injected into a human
being when the Anopheles
mosquito takes a blood meal.
We're going to be
talking about drugs for
the liver stage,
but mostly drugs for
the erythrocytic stage.
Most of the drugs,
all but two.
are effective in the
erythrocytic stage.
Clinical features now.
Falciparum malaria,
Plasmodium falciparum
malaria, is the most likely
to cause illness,
including severe illness.
plasmodium falciparum is
the most widespread in
the world and the resistance
is most widespread
among the falciparum
species so uncomplicated
patient is ill patient
presents with the fever
and the ill feeling and
some anemia as hemolysis
is occurring, and a
palpable spleen sometimes.
These patients can
take oral drugs,
oral treatment.
Severe malaria now is very
serious. It can be fatal.
High-level parasites in the
bloodstream, hyperparasitemia.
Extensive hemolysis,
which, of course,
severe anemia
follows from that.
Seizures.
Hypotension and shock.
Hypoglycemia, as
the parasites are
using up the sugar
in the blood,
which is important
for their growth.
Acute kidney injury
which follows from
all of this
hemolysis and all of
this hyperparasitemia
that's going on.
Acidosis, pulmonary
edema with acute
respiratory distress
syndrome, coma,
and that can be
followed by death.
So this is an emergency
it needs to be
treated rapidly, and
it's treated with
parenteral drug,
parenteral treatment.
So, IV, preferably, I am okay.
So diagnostics.
The lab can pick up the
parasites within the red
cells by gamsa staining
and of the thick and
thin blood smears. I have
some pictures of that.
This is normal. This
is what normal red
blood cells look
like. This is a
lymphocyte. We have
our platelets in here.
This is a picture of
hemolysis here with
merozoites flowing
into the blood stream
ready to infect other
red blood cells.
This is a picture of
a thick blood smear.
Thick blood smears are
useful for detecting
the malaria parasites.
It's a A larger amount
of blood is used than
in the thin blood
smear, so the parasites
may be easier to spot.
However, it does
not provide detailed
information about
the parasite species.
So the thin blood smear
is used for that, and here
the various malaria parasites
can be differentiated
and also the age of them.
Here's the ring form,
young trophozoite, a
little older trophozoite.
Here we have infection
of the erythrocytes,
mature schizont,
female gametocyte,
male gametocyte.
so this will be very helpful
in guiding treatment choices
so the goals well let's
see prevention prevention
of malaria in the non
-immune travelers that
would certainly be first
and foremost prevention of
malaria and its complications
for those people
who live, actually live
in the endemic regions
and are at high risk for
severe disease. The people
who are at highest risk
for severe disease are
the young children,
infants and young children.
Most deaths from
plasmodium falciparum in
these endemic regions
is in children five
and under. And pregnant
people are also at
higher risk for
developing severe malaria.
Prophylaxis, chemoprophylaxis.
The antimalarial
drug can prevent the
development of
sympathetic malaria caused
by the asexual
erythrocytic forms only.
Well, mainly only.
that's one drug that's
available available
that can that has a
broader effect treatment
the artemisinin now these
are very short-acting
very important group of drugs
i mentioned them earlier
with the Mekong Delta
region, sub-region, where
the artemisinin resistance
is starting to emerge.
Artemisinin are
preferred treatment.
Chloroquine can be used
for chloroquine-sensitive
malaria only, which
is very few regions of
this world. It can also
be used for non-falciparum
malaria. Chloroquine
is still useful for
anything other than
plasmodium falciparum malaria.
No one agent is effective
against both the latent
liver stage and the
blood stage of P. vivax
and P. ovale. These two
species are the only two
that cause this latent
liver stage. They
lay dormant in the
liver and they can cause
a resumption of
illness later on.
So the schizontoside, this
is the blood schizontoside,
erythrocytic
schizontoside, plus one of
these two drugs, is required
to affect this radical
cure. Radical cure meaning
prevention of relapse
by eradicating PVVax and
POVALI from the liver.
here's the list of drugs
see there are stars on them
I put stars only on the drugs
that are used in the United
States or have been used
in the United States they
are arranged according to
their duration of activity.
Long-acting ones here,
chloroquine, I've
mentioned before,
mefloquine.
These are the two main
ones that we think
about for prophylaxis
in this group.
Sulfidoxine,
pyrimethamine is no longer
available. I'll go into
more detail on that later.
Lumafantrine. Long
-acting is available
only in combination
with the artemisinin.
And then we have shorter
-acting, not short
-acting, but shorter
-acting oral drugs,
which can be used for
prophylaxis, but they
require more frequent
dosing than these do.
And they're also
used for treatment.
Now we have our short
-acting drugs. These are
the artemisinin. So it's
an artemisinin class,
but artemisinin is also
a drug in the class.
And artemisir artesunate,
which is only parenteral.
So it's only parenteral.
What is that saying
to you? Oh, that must be
used for severe malaria.
You are correct.
Dihydroartemisinin.
Dihydroartemisinin is
actually a metabolic
active metabolite
of the metabolic
process, but it's
also a drug, but it's
not available in
the United States.
And quinine, which is
not an artemisinin.
I'll go into more
detail when we get to
quinine. Now we have our
slow acting antimalarial
drugs. That means
their onset is slow.
Doxycycline and clindamycin.
I'm sure those look
familiar to you. They are
antibacterial agents in
the protein synthesis
prophylaxis inhibitor class.
But they're also used in
the treatment of malaria.
And we can see
doxycycline is also
used in the
prophylaxis of malaria.
These down here are not
available in the United
States, and I'm not
asking you to memorize
them. You may see them
if you go on a mission
trip, a medical mission
trip, to some of these
other countries that are
malaria-endemic areas.
Okay, so what do they do?
I put this chart up here
so you can begin to see
patterns. You can look
at it as a whole, and it
can help you to understand
the relationships between
these drugs and maybe
help you conceptualize.
remember it better.
So looking at this group here,
these are all useful against
the erythrocytic stage only.
These on the bottom, group
number three, primoquine
and tefenoquin, are useful
against the liver stages.
We're thinking about them
mainly for the
Hypnozoite stage.
That's the dormant liver stage.
Now the
Tifenoquin, before I
go on to gametocytes,
this is the newest
agent in the group as
of now and it has
much broader activity.
Sporozoites.
So that's the
sporozoites are what the
mosquito injects into
the human being. The
primary liver stage,
the latent liver stage,
the erythrocytic stage,
and the gametocyte.
Why is gametocyte
important? Because it is
the gametocyte that's
taken up by the mosquito
in a blood meal. And
this is how malaria just
keeps being transmitted
from one person to
the next person to the
next person and so on.
So it would be great if
the drugs would kill the
gametocytes but really only
three of them do reliably and
that is the artemisinin
and these two on the bottom
primoquine and tefenoquin.
Those are the only ones
that have reliable activity
against the gametocytes.
So that's how to think
about it. The drugs that are
useful against the erythrocytic
stage, the drugs that
are useful against the
hypnozoites, and the drugs that
are useful against that
will kill the gametocytes.
That's it.
Chemoprophylaxis. I've
listed them out here.
Chloroquine. This is
the Tovacone proguanol.
Mephloquine.
Doxycycline.
Tefenoquin and
Primoquin. I'm sort of
putting a little box
around because these are
the ones in group
three that I mentioned
before. I'll go into
more detail on that.
So we're talking
about prophylaxis of
infection, of infected
red blood cells in
chloroquine sensitive
areas, which are very few,
for plasmodium
falciparum. but it's also
useful for P. vivax,
P. ovale, P. nalisi,
P. malariae, the non
-falciparum species.
So that's what
chloroquine is useful for.
Methyloquine and etoblchone
proguanol, doxycycline,
are all commonly used for
prophylaxis of malaria
for travelers going to
endemic malaria regions.
Tephenaquin is effective
against all of these species.
It's mainly used for prevention
of the hypnozoites of
P. bebex and P. ovale. I
should say for eradication.
Now, you do need to
know how these are used.
Chloroquine,
methoquine, once weekly.
So, just once a week.
It's that long acting.
Starting one or two
weeks before traveling in
order to get the blood
levels up. I'm sure you
remember about steady
state and all of that.
And then to continue for
four weeks after coming back.
The patient may be, I
should say the traveler may
be carrying some malaria,
may not be symptomatic.
but once the person
comes back the drug
should be continued
just in case there are
some malaria parasites
within that patient.
Mefloquine same deal except it
starts two to three
weeks in advance.
Now etovoquine proguanol
and doxycycline
I mentioned had
shorter half-lives.
These do need to be
taken once a day.
Once a day, every day,
easy enough to do.
Etovacone Proguanol,
it's just started a
couple of days
before traveling and
completing the course
a week after returning.
Doxycycline should be
taken for another four
weeks after. Remember,
that is a slow-acting drug.
Now, let's talk
about these two.
Tifenequin, once weekly,
and it does need a loading
dose. Tifenequin, a
loading dose is taken
three days before exposure,
then once weekly, starting
seven days after that
loading dose, and then
once weekly for the
duration of the treatment.
So tefenoquin actually
does have activity against
the liver and blood stages
of plasmodium species
and it is approved by
the FDA to be taken for
prophylaxis against these.
It is expensive, though,
compared to the others.
Primoquin,
shorter half-life, once daily.
It can be taken for
prophylaxis, but it's only going
to be useful against P,
VVACs, and P. ovale. So it
can't be the only one
that's used in areas where
Plasmodium falciparum or the
other species are endemic.
Anyway, Primoquin one to two
days before, seven days after.
And it's mainly
used for a radical
cure, which I put down here.
14 days, once daily
for 14 days to
prevent relapse in
case the patient is
carrying PVVax or
POVoli parasites.
This is upon return. once
the patient gets back
will not be exposed to
malaria anymore then would
take this for the radical
cure now pregnancy
chloroquine yes methylquine
yes all the rest no
children there are dosing
there's dosing information
safety information available
for all of them for
all of all of the drugs
for pediatric patients.
Treatment now.
Let's talk about
malaria falciparum.
Treatment of malaria
caused by the
falciparum species.
So uncomplicated.
Well, you see
artemether in here,
so you know it's
an artemisinin.
Artemether is paired with
lumafantrine, which
is long-acting.
This is available in the US.
It is the preferred treatment.
It's twice daily for
three days. That's
the entire course of
treatment. If the patient
has been somewhere
where there is a
resistance, it may take
a little bit longer.
I put this part in here not
for you to memorize these
things but to become aware
that dosing there can be
dosing issues in patients
who are of heavier weight.
This is becoming an area of
Increasing awareness.
The literature is starting
to list dosing for
patients that are heavier,
but it's still pretty,
it's still not available
for most drugs. I just
want you to be aware of
it. I don't want you to
memorize this at this
point. It's not necessary.
All right, I've
listed here some
combinations available
outside the U.S.
Again, you don't have
to memorize these, but
we can see that they
are still three days.
These are once daily, but
even twice daily isn't
so bad for three days.
It's easy to stick to.
I've listed them. You don't
have to memorize them.
All right, severe malaria now.
Artesanate.
artesanate. So we have
severe falciparum malaria
with no established
artemisinin resistance
and with established
artemisinin resistance.
So how do we monitor this?
Artemisinin ACT is
preferred because it's rapid
acting, short acting
artemisinin combined with
a long-acting drug. Plus
it's really effective.
So how do we know? We
monitor the parasite density.
After the therapy
is given, the smears
are viewed under the
microscope and we
can see how well the
patient is doing.
So for no established
artemisinin resistance. We
give the artesanate at 0,
12, and 24 hours, so those
three doses, and then it'll
be followed once daily
until the parasite density
is less than one percent.
And the patient is
switched over to oral
therapy as soon as the
patient can tolerate it.
So severe malaria with
established artemisinin
resistance is the same
thing. Same approach.
Follow the therapy until
there's less than 1%
parasite density. Patient
takes the oral ACT as soon
as it's tolerable. Same
thing. It might take a
little longer. The therapy
duration might be a little
longer for established
artemisinin resistance.
Now, what do we do in
the United States? Well,
artesanate, number one,
is super-duper expensive.
We don't have a lot
of malaria, thank
God, in the United
States. And therefore,
most hospital pharmacies are
not going to be stocking it.
So, what is to be
done in that interim
before the artesanate
is available? The
patient needs to be
treated right away.
Okay, well, ******, if
the patient can swallow
and keep the pills down,
that would be fine,
or via a nasogastric
tube if the
patient is unable
to swallow tablets.
And this course of
therapy is followed
until that artesanate
is available.
There are resources for
acquiring artisanate
in emergency situations
like this, so it can
be obtained. It's just
there may be a delay.
I put boxes around
the United States
alternate therapies.
You don't need to
memorize the ones
outside the U.S. for now.
so what about the
pregnant individual
travelers well don't go
because pregnant people
are at risk for severe
malaria at greater
risk than an adult a
normally healthy adult
if necessary either
chloroquine or mefloquine
because they have
been shown after
all these decades to
be safe in pregnancy.
For people who live
in endemic areas,
there is something called
intermittent preventive
treatment, which of
course has an acronym,
IPT, for pregnant people.
What is this? This
is SP. So what is SP?
It is sulfidoxine.
pyrimethamine. This
is the one that I said
is not available in the
United States anymore
because there's so much
resistance to it. However, when
it's used like this in
endemic regions for pregnant
people, given at four doses,
one month apart, up until
38 weeks and beginning at
about 13 weeks, this can
prevent the malaria illness
in the pregnant individual.
Severe malaria, well,
artesanate, of course.
Switch to oral ACT when
tolerated, same thing.
Uncomplicated, same thing.
artemisin and lumifantrine
all trimesters the
others are recommended for
second and third trimesters
but if the artemisin
and lumifantrine isn't
available then one of these
can be used now another
alternative is quinine
quinine with clindamycin
quinine is the short
-acting, clindamycin is the
longer-acting or slow-acting,
and this can be used in
all trimesters of pregnancy.
So all trimesters,
artemisin and lumefantrine,
quinine and clindamycin.
Not together, one or the other.
So children, children
at high risk for severe
malaria in Endemic
regions. There are programs
now for seasonal malaria
chemo prevention. So
this would be the rainy
season in these areas.
Intermittent dosing during peak
malaria transmission seasons.
I'll go into more
detail on this.
And perennial malaria
chemo prevention. These are
areas where malaria can
be around be there be in
the region year-round.
Again intermittent dosing.
The WHO recommendation
is again sulfidoxine
pyrimethamine because
we're preventing
along with this long
-acting agent here.
aq stands for
amodiaquin which i'm not
asking you to memorize
but this is the general
idea you should have
the general idea
vaccines question that's
been since the beginning
of vaccine time why are
there no vaccines against
malaria well malaria changes
itself very often but with
the recently with the
technology that's available
now two vaccines have been
developed i'm not asking
you to memorize this i just
want you to be aware of
it and they are intended
for uh vaccinating children
from the five from five
months of age and on up.
It's a four-shot regimen,
one dose monthly, monthly
intervals, and
then a fourth dose.
With the first one that
was developed, which has a
name Moskoritz, it's given
18 months following the
third dose and the newer
one r21 matrix m at 12
months of course doses at
12 months otherwise they're
very the requirements are
very similar the they're
both efficacious when
given before the high
transmission season safety has
been demonstrated in clinical
trials of course safety
monitoring is continuing
and it's expected to
have a high public health
impact when implemented
broadly 28 African countries
do plan, have done, or plan
to introduce this program
as part of their national
immunization efforts.
And the good thing is
that it's cost effective.
It's just a few dollars
per dose at this time,
which is comparable to
giving the drugs for
prophylaxis and also
other childhood vaccines.
So let's begin with the
pharmacology now
of all these drugs.
Chloroquine and
hydroxychloroquine
are virtually the same.
Slightly different dosing,
but that's the only
difference. I'm going to
talk about chloroquine,
but if you hear the
name hydroxychloroquine,
you know that everything
you heard about
chloroquine applies
to hydroxychloroquine.
They are blood schizonticides
for the prophylaxis
and treatment of chloroquine
-sensitive malaria.
erythrocytic stage and they
may be used in pregnancy.
There is worldwide chloroquine
resistance of P. falciparum.
P. falciparum resistance.
And as I've mentioned
a few times now, P.
falciparum is the most
widespread species in the
world and there is a
great deal of resistance
against it, chloroquine
resistance. But I've
listed the chloroquine
sensitive regions here,
Central America, west
of the Panama Canal,
the Dominican Republic,
parts of the Middle East,
and for a long time,
Haiti. But now resistance
is being reported.
So if a patient comes
back from a visit in Haiti
with signs and symptoms of
malaria, borne out by blood
smears, treat as though
it's a resistant strain.
Pharmacology. Okay.
All of this pharmacokinetics
is important to understand
in order to treat the
patient properly. It has a
huge volume of distribution.
Huge volume of distribution,
a loading dose needs to
be given for treatment.
Recall that for
prophylaxis, it needs to be
taken one to two weeks
prior to traveling.
CYP3A4.
Unchanged drug goes
out through the
urine, and so does
the metabolites.
So why has this got
a large volume of
distribution? Because it
sequesters in tissues.
It sequesters in
so many tissues.
including melanocytes.
So think of anything that's
got color in it. This
comes from the melanocytes,
the retina, skin,
etc.
Half-life, three to
five days initially.
Well, that makes sense
that the drug could
be taken once a week
for prophylaxis.
And because it's
sequestered in all these
tissues, it takes a couple
of months to clear out.
It takes more than a couple
You don't have to memorize
doses. I have them in
here as a basis of
comparison. So once weekly, a
person will take 500
milligrams for prophylaxis.
But for treatment, in a two
-day course of treatment.
It's two and a half grams,
five times the amount.
That's the takeaway
message here. The
treatment dose, even
though treatment is
only a couple of days,
it's a large dose.
Mechanism of action
enters the food vacuole of
parasites, disrupts
sequestration, oxidative
damage to membrane, and
critical biomolecules.
I'll go into more detail
on the next slide.
And resistance.
Chloroquine resistance
transporter. Chloroquine
resistance transporter,
PFCRT, is expressed on
the membrane of the food
vacuole. That's how the
drug gets in into the
kitchen of the parasite.
So if it can't
get into the food
vacuole, it's therefore
not going to be
effective in eradicating
the parasite.
And this is caused by a
simple point mutation,
K76T, in that PFCRT gene.
Other mechanisms
are P-glycoprotein.
Here we go again.
P-glycoprotein. I'm
sure you're getting
used to seeing that.
PF, plasmodium falciparum,
and MDR. Remember, MDR1,
multi-drug resistance
type 1, is P-glycoprotein.
now we have our plasmodium
falciparum multi-resistance
protein and other transporter
gene mutations that
are may also be involved
this is the big one pfcrt the
most important one at this
time mechanism this is
hemoglobin and i made another
picture here this is heme
and this is heme
here so you can
maybe visualize it more easily.
The parasite eats the protein
but it doesn't eat the
heme so the heme gets
left over. Heme is
toxic so it packages the
hemazoin into these
crystalline structures.
It packages the
free heme into these
crystalline structures
that are called hemozoin.
That detoxifies
the free heme and
therefore the
plasmodium is able to
proliferate and go
on through its life.
Now it is believed
that chloroquine and
hydroxychloroquine prevent
the packaging up of the heme,
the polymerization of
all this free heme into
hemazoin, leaving all
of this heme to be free
to cause cellular damage,
oxidative damage to
membranes, digestive
proteases, other critical
biomolecules. And in the
end, the parasite bursts,
the red cell bursts,
and the malaria density,
parasite density, will
diminish, especially with
treatment.
Adverse effects. Well, there's
quite a list here. With
the low prophylactic dose,
it's really generally well
tolerated. Remember, it's
only 500 milligrams a week.
Can cause some GI
irritation, but taking
it with food can help
that. And patients
might get rashes.
Remember, it goes into
the melanocytes. Maybe
get some headaches.
High treatment dose. Well,
more side effects itching
and diarrhea nausea
vomiting headache visual
disturbances rash photosensitivity
acute toxicity so what
is this this is too rapid
IV infusion and not IV
is no longer available in this
country because chloroquine
really does have a
narrow safety margin long
-term use what are we thinking
about autoimmune disorders
such as rheumatoid
arthritis. This is a DMARD.
Hydroxychloroquine is a DMARD.
Chloroquine can also be used.
So cardiovascular problems
with arrhythmia, AV block,
ECG changes, skin changes,
blue gray pigmentation,
dermatitis,
phototoxicity and rations,
severe skin reaction,
severe hypoglycemia,
ototoxicity,
retinopathy, remember
pigment is in the retina,
myopathy, peripheral
neuropathy, agitation,
anxiety, confusion,
neuropsychiatric effect.
So this was long-term high
cumulative doses. This is
not what we see in the
prophylaxis and treatment of
malaria this is when it's
used long term for autoimmune
disorder interactions well
this is definitely not
a complete list but you'll
get an idea anything that
will decrease its absorption
antacids uh cyp3a4
inducers inhibitors of course
you're well familiar with
that and anything that's
got similar adverse effects.
Those are the main concepts
of drug-drug interactions.
And now mefloquine. It's
a blood schizontoside,
prophylaxis, and
treatment of chloroquine
-resistant malaria,
the erythrocytic
stage, and yes, it can
be used in pregnancy.
Okay, mefloquine is an
alternative. It's not
first line and the reason
is the adverse effects.
But let's go through the
pharmacokinetics first.
CYP3A4 to inactive
metabolites and a long half
-life. Those are the
basic takeaway points.
250 milligrams a week
for prevention but much
higher dose for treatment.
The same as we saw,
same kind of idea as we
saw with chloroquine.
Mechanism is really unknown.
Resistance, it seems to
be amplification of this
plasmodium falciparum
multi-drug resistant one.
What's another name for
that? P-glycoprotein.
And there is high-level
resistance in mainland
Southeast Asia now. okay side
effects so neuropsychiatric
effects mefloquine has
long been associated with
this particular adverse
effect more so than the
other drugs so anxiety
depression confusion if a
person is feeling these
things it may actually be a
prodrome to psychosis and
people who've never had a
psychosis episode can
develop it with mefloquine.
Dizziness, vertigo, loss
of balance can also occur.
If these symptoms
occur with prophylactic
use, the patient should stop
taking them and use
a different drug.
Caution in activities
requiring mental
alertness. So what are we
thinking about? Pilots,
people driving cars, people
operating heavy machinery, etc.
Methlequin should
not be prescribed for
prophylaxis or treatment
of patients with major
psychiatric disorders.
That's the big takeaway
with methlequin and
the adverse effects.
so who do we not give it
to other contraindications
people who have a
history of seizure
disorder people with
cardiac disease people with
blood disease people
with liver disease liver
insufficiency people
who have severe
skin problems people
who have been allergic
to Well, that's
true with all drugs.
And so on.
So, atofoquin proguanil now.
This comes in a fixed
combination tablet.
I put the doses here. You
don't have to memorize those.
It is a blood schizonticide
for prophylaxis
and treatment of chloroquine
-resistant malaria
orycerocytic stage.
Would all these drugs be
useful against chloroquine
-sensitive malaria?
Yes.
But what do we use for that?
Chloroquine.
Etoboquine and progronal
act synergistically.
And etoboquine is highly active
against the erythrocytic.
That's what we're thinking
about. And the primary
hepatic stage. that's
the first stage when the
sporozoites are injected
into the human being and go
to the liver and then
multiply and then go out into
the bloodstream it's not
effective against the hypnozoites
and it's not used in
pregnancy because there's
a lack of safety data on
it. That's the main reason.
Etobiquone, oral naturally,
proguonyl oral naturally,
highly plasma protein bound.
Etobiquone is not significantly
metabolized and it
goes out through the feces,
this is unchanged drug,
half-life three days.
Okay, that's pretty decent
half-life but it's still
a shorter half-life
than we see with
chloroquine and mefloquine.
Proguanol, CYP2C19 is
necessary to be active
to convert it to
cycloguanol. And it
is cycloguanol that
has the main activity.
Proguanol and cycloganol
go out through the
urine, and the half
-life is up to 20 hours.
So together with a tovaquan,
it can be taken once
a day, and it will be a
useful prophylactic drug.
It should be taken
with fatty food
because of the low
bioavailability.
And the fatty food
really significantly
increases the bioavailability.
Mechanism of
action, I'll go into
more detail on the next slide.
Basically, etovoquan
causes collapse of the
parasite mitochondrial
membrane potential.
Cycloguanol inhibits
this dihydrofolate
reductase thymidylate
synthetase,
which is an enzyme
that does both jobs.
So what are we
thinking about here?
Folate synthesis, correct?
and interestingly,
it's been found that
proguanol itself,
not the cycloguanol,
the proguanol,
contributes to the
collapse of the
parasite mitochondrial
membrane potential.
It doesn't do that when
it's given by itself, but it
seems to synergize with the
etoboquin and help it out.
generally well tolerated
some abdominal pain nausea
vomiting the usual stuff
can take it with food and
that'll help but you're
supposed to be taking it with
a fatty food anyway to
improve bioavailability and
then headache dizziness
elevated serum transaminases
thinking about the liver
it's reversible hepatitis
is reported it's rare can
happen I want to be alert.
So CYP2C19, anything
that reduces CYP2C19
activity is going to
reduce cycloaguanol
levels, and that's going
to reduce efficacy.
So that's a lookup.
Look it up before you
prescribe it. There are
plenty of drug interaction
tools out there. You
can put the list of
drugs that the patient
is taking in there, and
one, two, three, out
the information comes.
This figure is from Harper's
Illustrated Biochemistry.
It's a McGraw-Hill textbook.
It is available on our website.
The etobacone binds to
cytochrome BC1, here,
on the inner membrane
of the mitochondria, and
that will inhibit the
electron transport, so
block this, block this,
and that will cause the
collapse of the mitochondrial
membrane potential.
Cycloiguanyl I mentioned
before and we'll mention again,
inhibits dihydrofolate
reductase, thimitolate
synthase, a double
-functioning enzyme,
and that will therefore
inhibit folate synthesis,
which inhibits the nucleotide
DNA and RNA synthesis.
Proguanol accentuates
mitochondrial membrane potential
collapsing action of the
etovacone, even though
it doesn't seem to do it
when it's given alone.
now sulfidoxame and
pyrimethamine this is still an
important concept even
though the drug is no longer
available in the united
states it is a blood's
gazonticide these two drugs
are together in a fixed dose
tablet and they do work
synergistically to inhibit
folate synthesis I'll go
into that in the next slide.
Long half-lives
prolong the exposure
of the body to the
drug, and that allows
selection of
resistant organisms.
And repeated exposure of
sulfidoxine pyrimethamine
in malaria endemic
regions contributes to
resistance. This drug
is available in so many
countries without a
prescription, people just go
and pick it up off the
shelf and take it however
they take it.
Avoidant pregnancy first
trimester. This is due to
pyrimethamine adverse
events observed in animal
reproduction studies. You
may recall that I mentioned
the SP treatment Prevent
to prevent malaria in
endemic regions starts at
13 weeks of pregnancy, so
after the first trimester.
And it continues through 38
weeks, so once a month
from 13 weeks to 38 weeks.
Intermittent preventive
treatment in pregnancy.
and patients who do
not have HIV who live
in these areas of high
malaria transmission.
Okay. Pharmacokinetics.
Sulfidoxine. That's
a sulfonamide.
Oral, slowly absorbed,
which is its particular
category because
it's such an old drug.
They were categorized
by their pharmacokinetics
in those days.
Highly protein
-bound, metabolism by
anesthetylation, just like
the other sulfonamides.
A great amount of the drug goes
out through the
urine unchanged.
You have to think
about renal dosing when
you see something like
that. And look at this
half-life, it's really
long, eight days.
Pyramathamine well
-absorbed, pretty highly
protein-bound, hepatic
metabolism, not too much
information on that
that's another very old
drug goes out through
the urine but not so much
just a a bit of it as
unchanged drug and half
-life is still long not
as long as sulfidoxine
okay mechanism of action
this figure actually
is from the katzung
pharmacology textbook
in the antibiotics chapter.
Here's trimethoprim.
Well, I'm using it.
Trimethoprim will inhibit
dihydrofolate
reductase in bacteria.
Pyramethamine
inhibits dihydrofolate
reductase in the parasite.
And here we have sulfonamide.
Well, sulfidoxine is
a sulfonamide. It acts like
every other sulfonamide.
It inhibits the
dihydroteroate synthase.
So we get this one-two punch
all on the same pathway.
Inhibit folate synthesis
at the first step
and inhibit folate
synthesis at this step.
Therefore, that
inhibits the formation
of the purines and
therefore DNA and RNA.
And if DNA and RNA are
inhibited, than the, well,
besides the fact that
it's not going to
function, it's also not
going to make its proteins.
Resistance, well, a
change in the target.
That's it. Just a
little change in
both targets, and
the drug becomes, the
bug becomes resistant
to the drug.
Sulfonamides,
sulfonamides, adverse
effects. Remember
all those terrible
skin reactions that can
occur in people who
are at risk for it.
And with pyrimethamine, we
can get some blood problems,
megaloblastic
anemia. Well, folate.
Folate inhibition can lead
to megaloblastic anemia.
Caution in patients with
folate deficiency, naturally.
Empatic or renal impairment.
History of seizure disorder.
For many, many, many
years, pyromesamine has
never been used in anybody
with G6PD deficiency,
but information
increases, and it is
now generally considered
safe for G6PD-deficient
patients when used
at therapeutic doses.
So these doses for
prophylaxis, this once
-monthly dose for this
intermittent prophylaxis,
it should be quite safe for
patients with G6PD deficiency.
So lumifantrine now,
this is the one that's
only in combination
with artemethanine,
sorry, artemether, and the
pharmacokinetics, pretty
much the same as we've
seen all throughout this
group of drugs, CYP3A4,
long half-life, don't
know how it works. It is
the blood's gazonticide.
Co-Artem is the name of this
Artemis or
Lumafantrine product,
which is a lot shorter
to say. Given it's a
three-day course, it
might need to be a little
longer if it's partial
resistance to the Artemis.
Mild QT interval prolongation
is not generally a
problem for anybody who's
taking this drug for
that three-day course.
However, there are certain
patients who are at increased
risk, so the patient
should be monitored
with the ECG monitoring.
Anyone who's got long
QT syndrome or taking
other drugs that are
increasing QT interval,
the drug can the
lumifantrine may increase
the risks how do we
know ECG monitoring
CYP3A4 inhibitors
it's going to reduce
efficacy potentially
CYP3A4 I said that wrong
CYP3A4 Your inhibitors
are going to increase
the risk of this QT
interval prolongation.
The inducers, of
course, are going
to decrease efficacy,
potentially.
Now let's talk about
the artemisinins
and then we'll
talk about quinine.
artemisinin comes from
a plant called artemisia
annua king wow which is
also called wormwood in case
you're familiar with that
uh artemether and artemis
and artesinate i put up
here art artemisinin you
need to know that word
because that's the name of
the class and artemisinin
as a drug, but it's not
combined, it's not in
combination with ACT here
in the United States. We
have artemether for that.
This is the structure.
Imagine this piece
coming out towards you.
This is called the
endoperoxide bridge,
absolutely essential for
its mechanism of action.
We'll talk about
artemither and artesinate.
First, artemither,
oral, high-fat meal.
Sounds familiar, doesn't it?
Highly protein-bound,
widely distributed,
CYP3A4 metabolism.
It's all the same.
This is an active metabolite,
the dihydroartemisinin.
Artemisinin, I referred
to that earlier, DHA.
So both Artemisir
and DHA are active.
It goes out through the urine
as inactive metabolites.
Half-life is two hours,
very short. Short
half-life, short acting,
used only for treatment.
It reaches its peak in
about two hours, so it
gets on board quickly
and I don't know how
many times I've mentioned
that now quite a few
artesanate I am or IV in
some countries where malaria
is endemic it is also
available rectally to get a
dose into the child usually
as quickly as possible
Articinate though is a
prodrug, plasma esterases
to DHA and the
dihydroartemisinin is the active
form and then
dihydroartemisinin undergoes
glucuronidation which is
inactive as they nearly always
are, and it goes out
through the air in that way.
Half-life of dihydrotomycinin,
barely over an hour.
Treatment of severe malaria.
Okay,
activity. All right, I
mentioned before that it's
this endoperoxide bridge
that is essential for
activity. Imagine this 3D
coming out towards you.
The artemisinin binds
to the free heme in
the food vacuole that's
been released after
digestion of the
hemoglobin by the parasite.
So this part will bind to
that free heme and then
covalent complexes are formed
and this is all supposed
proposed the drug then will
disrupt heme detoxification
they believe and it will
certainly increase the
oxidative stress by increasing
oxidative stress that's going
to cause structural damage,
inhibition of nucleic
acid synthesis, inhibition
of protein synthesis, etc.
So resistance.
I point to this
figure here now.
There is partial resistance and
this is the proposed mechanism.
This whole, This protein
structure here is the
PFK13, they call it, and
it's got a propeller domain.
You see these parts
of the protein here?
These are called
propeller domains.
So, point mutations
in these propeller
domains, and these
mutations are shown
here by these little
orange spheres.
are associated with
delayed parasite clearance.
Delayed clearance,
that means that the
drug therapy needs to
be on board for a longer
period of time than
the normal three days.
Downregulation of the
metabolic activity in
the ring stages, remember
those trophozoites.
Reduced activation
and conversion of
artemisinin drugs to the
reactive intermediates.
So if it doesn't
go through this
process, then it's
not going to work.
And at this point, it's just a
matter of extending
the therapy.
Okay, what does the drug do?
Active against the
asexual erysocytic
stages and all
plasmodia species.
effective against the
gametocytes but nothing in the
liver stages. It also is
effective against other types
of parasites which I'm not
asking you to memorize for
this lecture but just
remember also other parasites.
WHO recommendations,
World Health Organization
recommendations used
only in combination with
longer-acting antimalarials
in order to deter
emergence of resistance
and prevent recrudescence.
Also,
well, that's it.
First-line treatment
of severe malaria and
uncomplicated malaria in
all populations. Everybody.
I put doses here. You
don't have to memorize
it. Just to give you
a hint it's going
to be four tablets
two times a day for
three days oops didn't
mean to change it
weight-based dosing
for the little
guys the infants
and the children
the first dose it is
twice a day i said but
the first dose should
be uh eight hours apart
ideally the artesanate
iv bolus or im for four
doses zero twelve twenty
four and forty eight hours
then once once a day after
that that's what the 48
hours is as you can see
treat until the parasitemia
is less than one percent
and switch over to
the oral as soon as the
patient can tolerate it oral
therapy must begin less
than four hours after
the last dose you don't
have to memorize that but
remember how short the
half-life of artesanate is.
And that's the reason for
starting it at that point.
Well, what about the gametocytes?
So in low transmission
regions, a single dose
of primoquine on day one
of treatment, along with
the ACT, will reduce the
gametocyte transmission. So
we know that the artemisinin
does, and we add the
primaquin to it, and that will
further ensure that the
gametocytes are eradicated.
Okay, so there's a big
exception. We do not
give primaquin to
pregnant people, young
infants, and breastfeeding
infants, and I'll
get into that when I
get to those drugs.
side effects well it's
generally well tolerated the
usual nausea vomiting diarrhea
and dizziness pretty common
with all of them some
neutropenia anemia acute
hemolysis that could be from
the drug it could be from the
malaria increases in the
serum transaminases so it's
going on in the liver there
the hepatocytes now something
called black water fever
and i'm going to get to
this again with quinine. This
is artesanate IV and people
who have high malaria
burden, high parasite burden.
There will be massive
hemolysis, massive bursting
of the red blood cells
with all of that hemoglobin
being released into the
bloodstream and the urine.
So the urine turns dark
red or black, black water,
fever, and kidney failure
can result. It can happen
one to three weeks after
therapy. It can be severe.
And of course, there's a higher
likelihood with a
higher parasite density.
So quinine now. Quinine's been
around a long, long, long time.
It's obtained from the bark
of the cinchona tree, and
the cinchona is native to
South America. It is a blood
schizonticide. Don't know
how it works. Short-acting,
used for chloroquine
-resistant malaria.
Will it work for
chloroquine-sensitive? Yes,
it will, but we use
chloroquine for that.
The erysocytic stage.
It can be used in
pregnancy, but it's
not preferred. Why?
Because it can cause recurrent
hypoglycemia, and
pregnant patients are
especially susceptible
to hypoglycemia.
Oral readily absorbed,
gets to peak in a
few hours. We do not
have the IV formulation
here. It's quite
dangerous to use.
It binds to alpha-1
acid glycoprotein.
Now, alpha-1 acid
glycoprotein is
something called a
heat shock protein.
In other words, in
times of stress,
the blood levels are elevated.
So if we have higher
blood levels of alpha-1
acid glycoprotein, there's
more of it around to
bind to the quinine.
So for people who are
being treated initially
with high parasite burden,
It may be that a higher
dose of quinine would
be used, and then the
dose would be reduced.
That can be determined
by response.
CYP3A4, P-glycoprotein
inhibitor.
Good bioavailability.
A little bit goes out
through the urine unchanged.
Half-life, about 11 hours
in the healthy individual.
18 hours in a person with
severe malaria, shorter
in healthy children, longer
in the older patient.
The takeaways here really
are that it's short
-acting, that it binds to
alpha-1-acid glycoprotein,
CYP3A4 inhibitor, and
it's short-acting.
therapeutic use uncomplicated
falciparum resistant
malaria as an alternative to
ACT ACT is going to be the
preferred co-administered
with a long one so it's co
-administered traditionally
and still with either
doxycycline or clindamycin
doxycycline first choice clindamycin
if it's young children
or pregnant individuals.
And I just put dosing
here. The point is
it's three times a
day for three days.
That's the point.
We see our three days again.
This is three times a day.
If the infection was
acquired in Southeast
Asia, what's going
on in Southeast
Asia? There's more
resistance there.
Seven days if infection was
acquired in Southeast Asia. it.
This is an FYI. No, you
don't have to memorize it.
The quinine is also used in
the treatment of abesiosis,
which is acquired by deer
ticks here in the Northeast.
Not so much in the
Southeast. In fact, not at
all in Southeast. It's
the Northeast and also
the upper Midwest. So
it's relevant to anyone
who plans to be working
in these regions.
Etovaquan with
azithromycin is actually
preferred. So here we
see our two antimalarials
being used for a
different protozoa,
which is babesiosis.
Toxicities. Well, we've
got quite a list here.
So synchonism.
Remember, it comes from
the cinchona trees.
That's where the
synchonism comes from.
This word comes from.
So mild synchonism. And
this can occur with the
therapeutic doses. Tinnitus
is an early symptom.
Early symptom.
So if the person
starts to get this
ringing or buzzing
sound in the ear,
and they're taking
quinine, it's very
likely related to
the quinine. if it's
just onset since the
drug was started.
Headache, vasodilation,
and sweating, and
nausea, dizziness, and
visual disturbances.
And these symptoms
can be quite severe
in severe
synchronicity, in which
case the quinine
should be stopped.
Now, hypoglycemia.
Very important adverse
effect of quinine,
especially in
pregnant individuals,
because it can be dangerous.
Severe malaria.
Hypoglycemia is dangerous
in patients with
severe malaria and
patients who are pregnant.
So what's causing
this now? What
is the cause of
the hypoglycemia?
Well, quinine can increase
sensitivity to insulin
And add that together
with the increased
consumption of blood
glucose by the parasites,
and of course by the
host who's quite ill, and
failure of the hepatic
gluconeogenesis process,
that can cause quite
a drop in blood sugar.
Hypotension? Well, rapid IV
infusion, which
we don't do here.
black water fever i
explained that one before
this was first seen with
the treatment of malaria
with quinine it's a
malarial hemolytic anemia
massive intravascular
hemolysis hemoglobinemia
hemoglobinuria anuria
renal failure and death
black water fever
thromocytopenia can occur
hypersensitivity
reactions, of course,
IV administration, quinine,
like quinidine, which
is an isomer of quinine.
It's cardiotoxic when it's
administered IV. Again,
we don't give it IV here.
We get the ECG changes and
ventricular arrhythmia.
And it's safe in
pregnancy. You just have
to keep a very close
eye on blood glucose.
All right.
Other drugs that cause
the same effects.
Metabolism-related CYP3A4
inducers and inhibitors.
P-glycoprotein inhibition.
Warfarin. Well, warfarin pops
up with practically every drug.
Neuromuscular blockers. Quinine
can enhance
neuromuscular block.
And antacids can
decrease the serum
concentrations of quinine,
so avoid it, and end
on a whole long list.
So that just gives you
a little taste of the
drug interactions.
And now, primoquine and
tefenoquin, these tissue
schizonticides for the treatment,
prevention and treatment
of the latent liver stages.
These are in the class
called eight aminoquinolines
because of their structure.
You can recognize it here
and recognize it here.
Tepenoquin.
Oral.
Well absorbed.
Widely distributed.
CYP1A2 and
some others.
Urine as metabolites.
Seven hours.
It's a range of four to ten.
It Absorption is
increased with a high
-fat meal. We see
that an awful lot.
Half-life of up to 15, sorry,
peak up to 15 hours.
So it takes a long
time to get to that
peak concentration.
High plasma protein binding.
Immense volume of distribution.
So what is that
saying? It's saying
it's sequestering
in the tissues.
Don't know how
it's metabolized.
And it's got a half-life of 15
days. it's a really
long half-life.
So be sure you can
understand and list
even how primoquine
and tefenoquine are
the same and how
they are different.
Okay, what do they
do? Liver stages,
okay, good. Active against
the dormant hypnozoites.
Gametacidal, so it'll
eradicate the gametes.
And I mentioned before,
a single dose of
primoquine along with
the ACT reduces that
gametocyte carriage and
transmission. If the
carriage goes down, the
transmission goes down.
Standard therapy for
radical cure. That means we
give the drug against the
erythrocytic stage and
the drug against the
liver stage. So two drugs.
Radical cure.
Tefenoquin, this is
another difference,
has substantial
activity against the
asexual erythrocytic
stages, but it's
not indicated for
acute infection.
It is FDA approved for
prophylaxis for both stages.
Primaquin can be given
to anyone of all ages,
tefenoquin, treatment
greater than 16 years of age,
prophylaxis greater than
18 years of age, with
a caveat, there must be
testing of G6PD levels.
I probably should
have put this in red,
so I'm putting a red
box around it now.
Now, testing of G6PD levels.
Okay, so perimeguin, 30
to 70% of activity, dose
reduction, equal to or
greater than 70% full dose.
Now, tefenoquin greater
than 70% only, nobody less.
If the testing
shows less than 70%
activity, then tefenoquin
cannot be given.
And I put the chemoprophylaxis
down there on the
bottom, which I've been
over before. All right,
let's talk about G6PD
deficiency a little bit.
This map shows the prevalence
throughout the world.
See this high prevalence
here in African
nations and here in
the Southeast Asia.
G6PD deficiency can
lead to hemolytic
anemia and also
methemoglobinemia
when these patients
are given oxidizing
drugs. like primoquine
and tefenoquine.
That's why the test for G6PD
deficiency is so essential
before administering
primoquine or tefenoquine.
I indicated the
recommendations on the previous
slide. I do want you
to know this. It is an
important concept whenever
you're going to be treating
anyone who could have
G6PD deficiency, not only
with our antimalarial
drugs, but other drugs
also that can cause
hemolysis in these patients.
Methemoglobinemia
is the type of
hemoglobin that does
not bind oxygen.
okay contraindications acutely
ill patients predisposed
to granulocytopenia other
potentially hemolytic
drugs and pregnancy so why
pregnancy because there is
the risk that the fetus
actually has g6 pd deficiency
and the drug does cross
the placenta get into the
fetal bloodstream and can
cause hemolysis in the fetus.
So the mechanism.
Here we have our glucose
6 phosphate. Glucose 6
phosphate dehydrogenase or
dehydrogenase, however you
want to pronounce it. NADP
here goes to reduced NADPH,
this is a reducing agent
now for glutathione, this
is reduced glutathione,
to GSH, and it goes back
to reduced glutathione. So
this cycle is very important
with the G6PD cycle in
red blood cells. This is
the main way that it manages
oxidative metabolites.
And if G6PD is missing,
then we lose these effects.
and we're no longer able to
detoxify the
oxidative metabolites.
Also, if the NADPH
is necessary for
converting methemoglobin
into hemoglobin.
And we have some bite
cells in here. This
is a little blister
cell. This is a little
bite cell that occurs
with patients who have
G6PD deficiency and
NADPH deficiency also.
And it's the result of
the mechanical removal
of the denatured
hemoglobin within the
splenic filtration. So
it causes these little
**** out of the sides
of the red blood cells.
All right, now doxycycline
and clindamycin.
So, why would we be using
these to treat malaria?
Well, first of all,
they're blood stage slow
-acting schizonticides,
it takes a while,
they don't eliminate
the liver stage, and
it causes something
called a delayed death
mechanism, that's
the slow-acting part.
They impair the expression
of something called
an apicaplast gene in the
parasite, and that That
leads to abnormal cell
division, which leads to
death as a progeny of
the plasmodium parasite.
So not the mature plasmodium
parasite, but its progeny.
And so that takes a while
for that effect to set in.
Doxycycline or
tetracycline, but
tetracycline has to
be taken more often.
Short-term prophylaxis in
chloroquine-resistant areas.
treatment as an adjunct to
quinine or even artesanate
for uncomplicated or if
necessary severe malaria.
Clindamycin in the
young child and infant
and in pregnant people.
Why? Because it can
cause, doxycycline can
cause discoloration
of the tooth enamel but
clindamycin doesn't.
doxycycline,
tetracycline, clindamycin
are not effective
as single agents for
acute malaria because
they take too long
common adverse effects
doxycycline, GI
upset, yeast infections
photosensitivity,
clindamycin,
diarrhea, skin rash
something called
pseudomembranous colitis
and this is related to
C. difficile C. difficile
that is associated
with clindamycin use
and that's pretty much
it so let's do check your
knowledge Susie is a 22 year
old healthy woman planning a
two-week mission trip to
West Africa with her church
group she doesn't have any
out no known drug allergies
she's provided with medication
to prevent malaria and
directed to start taking
it once daily with a fatty
food two days before
traveling to continue for the
duration of the stay and for
seven days after her return.
She packs lightweight
long-sleeved
shirts and long
pants, bug spray with
DEET, and insecticide
-treated bed nets.
So it's not just the
drugs. We need to do non
-drug methods to try and
prevent mosquito bites.
And what is the
mechanism of the drug
described, and why
should the drug be taken
with fatty food? Okay,
what is she taking?
Once daily, starting two
days before traveling,
and continuing for seven
days after her return.
Taking it daily
during her stay.
Okay,
etovacone proguanol.
Etovacone binds the
cytochrome BC1 complex
on the inner membrane
of the mitochondria.
Leading to collapse
of the parasite
mitochondrial
membrane potential.
Cycloguanol inhibits
dihydrofolate
reductase thymetylate
synthase enzyme.
And proguanol itself
accentuates the mitochondrial
membrane potential
collapsing action.
And why is the tovoquan
proguanol taken with
fatty food? To improve
absorption and also
it can help relieve
the GI side effects.
Andy is a 50-year-old
male being sent by his
company to Central Africa
to oversee a new division.
He has a history of major
depression managed with
meditation, exercise, diet,
and countryline dancing.
He has no drug allergies,
no known drug allergies.
Which antimalarial
prophylaxis medication
should be avoided
for Andy and why?
Well, chloroquine, because
it's likely to not work.
Mefloquine, because of
the neuropsychiatric
side effects, and the patient
has a history of
major depression,
can also cause dizziness
and vertigo and loss
of balance. And we
don't know exactly what
he's going to be doing
there, but I'm sure
he's going to need to
be alert for his job.
Sulfidoxine
pyrimethamine is not
recommended because
of resistance.
And short-acting drugs
are for treatment,
not for prophylaxis.
what anti-malarial
drugs would be
appropriate for andy
etovacone progonal or
doxycycline that's it
jp is a 38 year old
jp is 38 years old and
planning a 10-day
trip to asia where the
predominant malarial
parasite is pv vax jp
is healthy with no
medical conditions nkda
Prescription is provided
for an antimalarial
drug for prophylaxis,
a parasitic infection
of the red cells.
What is the drug? What
are the directions
for taking it and why?
Chloroquine.
So PVVax, chloroquine
will be useful for that.
One to two weeks before
traveling, then weekly
during the stay, and then
four weeks after returning.
Chloroquine has an initial
half-life of three to five
days and a terminal half
-life of one to two months.
Chloroquine is sequestered
in tissues, liver, spleen,
kidney, lung, brain,
spinal cord, melanocytes.
When JP returns to the
U.S., he is provided
a prescription for a
long-acting drug taken as
a single dose and
directed to continue the
antimalarial drug he
was taking during his
stay once weekly for an
additional four weeks.
What is the purpose of
the additional drug?
What are two
contraindications to its use?
Tefenequine is
prescribed to eradicate
the PVVAC hypnozoites
and prevent relapse.
Tefenequine is
contraindicated in people with
G6PD deficiency and less
than 70% of activity.
G6PD screening must
be performed before
prescribing either to
fenoquin or primoquine.
The fenoquin is also not
approved for
pediatric patients.
And I've given you
the age ranges.
AK is a 25-year-old woman
invited to a family wedding
in West Bengal in one
month. She was born in the
U.S. and is pregnant at 23
weeks gestation. She states
that she is excited to
see her family, whom she
has not visited in 10 years.
For malaria prophylaxis,
which of the following is
the best option for her?
Don't go is the best option.
Malaria infection in pregnancy
is the major cause of
maternal death, maternal
anemia, miscarriage, preterm
birth, fetal growth
restriction, low birth weight,
stillbirth, congenital
infection, neonatal mortality.
Pregnancy increases
the chances of
developing severe malaria
and severe disease.
P. falciparum infected red
blood cells can sequester
in the placenta and cause
adverse pregnancy outcome.
Angelica is a previously
healthy 4-year-old female
who presents to the ED
with fever and chills,
rapid heart rate,
rapid breathing weight,
headache, fatigue,
nausea, diarrhea,
joint, and muscle
pains for 24 hours.
Signs and symptoms of
severe disease are absent.
History is significant for
recent travel to Haiti.
NKDA, I left that part out.
Physical exam and
laboratory findings are
consistent with P.
falciparum infection.
The patient is able to
take oral medication.
Which of the
following is the first
-line therapy for this patient?
Yes, of course. ACT,
Artemis and Unlumafantrine.
The tablets can be
crushed and mixed in
water if the patient
can't swallow the pills.
Artesanate is given IV or
IM for the treatment of
severe malaria until the
patient can take oral meds.
Chloroquine is
effective also for
sensitive plasmodium infection.
But there are reports of
chloroquine resistance in
Haiti, so we don't want
to take a chance. We don't
know which it is that
she's been infected with.
Quinine would be effective,
but is not preferred
because it can cause hypoglycemia
and black water fever.
Toxycycline is not
given to patients
less than 8 years
old because it can
cause discoloration
of tooth enamel.
Clindamycin would be
given in that case.
Primaquin is for the
eradication of PVVax and POVALI.
Hypnozoites for radical cure.
And here are the
tables I mentioned.
That's just condensing
everything here for you. And
that concludes the lecture
on the antimalarial drugs.